hi Kelly Clarkson where the Thor not
family I'm Julie I'm Chloe
I'm Brett hi I'm Kirk I'm Carson I'm rim
we recently went viral with our Disney
right videos that were put out there on
social media please keep your hands arms
feet and legs inside the boat and watch
the children and no flash pictures
prepare to make sail we did these two
dizzy rides just why we've been home in
isolation and just kind of did them
together as a family of something fun to
do
we just started kind of putting it
together by remembering some of our
favorite parts of the Wrights it's
Disneyland's been closed we've been kind
of missing it my favorite part of them
in the video was going down the stairs
in the slide I really like it how my
foots famous now welcome polish Moyles
we've been dying to meet you
make sure to stand in the dead center of
the room all this is not about the
videos but it's about spending quality
time with your family and reconnecting
it could be two board games videos just
anything that brings the family together
we'd like to challenge the rest of you
moms that are watching this in families
to go ahead and join the campaign and
thanks again Kelly for having us thank
you
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going